The MCU is going where it never dared to go
before — specifically, to the Netflix shows.
"That's it, let the Devil out."
"Spider-Man: No Way Home" begins directly
after the events of "Spider-Man: Far From
Home," with Peter Parker on the run after
his identity is outed.
Now on the run, Peter's life as he once knew
it is over.
With safety hard to come by, Peter is desperate
to set things right, teaming up with Doctor
Strange to make the world forget he's Spider-Man.
Naturally, hijinks ensue.
In addition to bringing a whole lot of bad
guys — and good guys — in from other movie
universe, Peter's adventure also leads him
to a lawyer who might look pretty familiar
to fans of the Netflix Marvel series.
That's right — it finally happened.
"So the Devil is back."
During one scene in "No Way Home," Peter is
sitting at a table with Aunt May, Happy Hogan,
and his mysterious lawyer -- the sunglasses-wearing
attorney Matt Murdock.
During the meeting, a brick gets thrown through
the window at blinding speed, with a note
attached to it from someone blaming Peter
for the death of Mysterio.
Parker can barely react before the blind Murdock
reaches out and catches it with lightning
reflexes, shocking even Peter himself.
When asked how exactly he did that, Murdock
responds,
"I'm a really good lawyer."
With that, it's as confirmed as can possibly
be that Matt Murdock, Daredevil powers and
all, is now officially a part of the big-screen
MCU.
"This change now, it feels significant."
He's never named directly in the scene -- it
is a proper cameo -- but the face of Charlie
Cox is unmistakable for Marvel fans.
The actor of course played this very same
lawyer in Marvel's Netflix series "Daredevil"
and the rest of the "Defenders"-associated
shows.
You might be thinking, "How do we know he's
the same version of the same character, not
just a nod to the character, like how J.K.
Simmons plays two versions of J. Jonah Jameson
that are clearly different people?"
"Mr. Jameson, there's a page six problem."
"We have a page one problem — shut up."
That's a fair question, and the answer remains
to be seen.
Does this mean that "Daredevil" and the other
Netflix shows are now fully canonical in the
MCU?
At this point, it's hard to say — especially
after "Loki" introduced the idea of variants
to characters we know across dimensions.
For all we know, Matt Murdock in "No Way Home"
and the Kingpin in "Hawkeye" might just be
the MCU versions of these characters, with
their Netflix adventures occurring in a slightly
different world.
Either way, we can probably count on Matt
and Peter crossing paths again — eventually.
Strange may have made everyone forget who
Peter is, but these characters have a comic
book history that's too big to ignore.
As New York-based heroes with enhanced reflexes,
the pair have had a lot of interactions and
team-ups before in Marvel lore.
In "The Spectacular Spider-Man" issues #27
through #30, Peter Parker gets blinded and
is aided by Daredevil until his recovery.
In "Daredevil" issues #305 and #306, the pair
team up to stop a vicious female serial killer.
A grieving, violent Spider-Man nearly kills
a criminal in rage in "The Spectacular Spider-Man"
#110 until Daredevil distracts the hero long
enough for him to come to his senses.
Their partnership is one of the stronger informal
team-ups in Marvel lore, so it's something
special to see Murdock finally get to help
out our favorite web-slinger.
Any fan of the comics has a lot to be excited
about now that Daredevil and Spider-Man are
finally united in the same cinematic universe.
And plenty of fans are probably just happy
to see Charlie Cox as Matt Murdock again.
In last year's Looper poll, we found out that
out of all the major canceled Netflix series,
"Daredevil" was far-and-away the one that
a clear majority of fans wanted to return.
The show grabbed a whopping 21% of all polled.
The show may still be off the air, but you've
got to admit — it looks like all those fans
just got their wish.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.